next we have a shrink telling us about
turning privacy trade-offs and policies
and an application to the US Census
hopefully you can't him know okay good
all right hi my name is ashwin I'm from
Duke University I'm going to talk to you
about something called policies and
differential privacy and also it was
asked to talk a little bit about work
with the US Census so I'm going to talk
a little bit over that as well the joint
work the few people among students a
deal bullying from Microsoft in the
census work this is the team through my
work at the census alright so the talk
outline is going to be i'm going to give
you sort of a high-level sort of look
into what you're trying to do with the
census at least the group that i'm
working with you're not going to talk
about any concrete algorithms but rather
give you sort of a halal idea of certain
challenges that they seem to face some
of which we have seen so much of which
I'm give you not I'm going to switch
gears then and talk a little bit about
some of my recent work and I'll tie them
together at the end of the talk alright
alright so I work with this group and
centers called the le HD longitudinal
employee household demographics and
basically what they what they have is a
data integration system that integrates
data from various different sources
federal state 10 census bureau data and
employers and employees ok so it's
households and employers and they use
this they take this data integrates data
from various sources and then release it
for public use I am going to show you
some examples of what those users are
but essentially you can think of their
scheme out to be as follows they have
three tables their work with table a job
table and a web-based table so the
vertical table basically has as you can
imagine properties of work workers so
just attributes a workplace table has
properties of workplaces so these are
just employers and a job table basically
has which worker is working
which place so for each each individual
you basically have a lot of Records
saying you start this job this time and
it at this time and so on okay and you
have things certain properties like
earnings that are associated with that
job okay so the goal is basically to
take this data and then create some
private version of the data and release
it so that you can do certain kinds of
analytics so to the analytics yeah so
the goal is to rescind their Gator so
the idea there is a sample from some
model built using a set of lower
daughter marginals the kinds of measures
you want to release our for instance the
average employment in the firm or CDF's
or quantiles or earnings of individuals
over time and you want to do that over a
large number of stratifying variables
like age sex race or work location
industry ownership and so on so one
thing I want to point out is this fairly
sparse because you can just look at
certain attributes like the home
location of the owner or the geography
of a workplace it's at the block census
block level there are 11 million blocks
in on the map so already the cross
product is fairly large and so the data
it's it's fairly fairly sparse and and
the margin of the day while you while I
call them lower order there there are
also fairly sparse because they usually
contain many of them contain the cross
product of the home location and the
work location so it's it's very spot
okay all right so what is the
application so one of the applications
is called on the map and this is like a
screenshot from a from a few years ago
and essentially what this plotting is
where people work and where people live
where people who work in them location
live and so it sort of plots commute
patterns of of people and you can
actually get reports of distributions of
a gender and so on for the people in
that workplace or people who reside in
certain certain locations okay and these
are the kinds of applications that they
want to power another day another
interesting application is sort of used
for emergency management's essentially
you look at a certain location and say
oh there was an emergency there and they
look at what kind of what what kind of
workplace demographic
are affected by that emergency so how
many people what kind of workers were
affected what the age distribution or
what are the industries and so on and
final application or a point out is
something called quarterly workforce
indicators these are things that
actually talk about unemployment
statistics new hires and separations how
many people who are hired how do you let
go average earnings in total employment
and these are used for various
interesting kinds of policy decision so
for instance if you want to figure out
where you want to create sort of
transitional training then you can use
this data to do that so it's a fairly
important data that needs to be
reasonably accurate okay all right so
what is sensitive so of course we think
about this data this individuals there
so you want the individual data to be
sensitive so it's like the standard p is
but also education and medical direct
medical records financial transaction so
on but you also want sort of business
information to be kept secret it seems
like sort of at least for the first time
when I heard it sound like why would
over a business one things to be private
especially things like the payroll or
the number of employees at a business
has turns out that the way census gets
this is through voluntary disclosure of
this information from the businesses and
if the if census does not protect the
privacy of the businesses then business
may no longer give the data to the
Census and so that basically defeats the
problem the promise of getting all of
this paper right state of the art so
tell 2008 all of all of the data that
was published was yes you know they're
there are businesses that are you know
huge yes
so don't you run into a sort of a
sensitivity problem yes yes then you'll
get that yes yeah there's a huge
sensitivity problem there ok I will get
to that if I don't get to that last
equation again okay so since 2008 so
they've also privacy is always been on
the mind of the census so they there's
this word for 50 years from the from the
journals of official statistics and so
they're being sort of using I'd have
protection metric measures to add noise
to the marginals before building model
these are really ad hoc when you
actually go and see the sea algorithms
you can't really prove anything in 2008
we helped them build a sort of building
differential privacy into a part of
their of their product so still the
workplace characteristics of protected
using sort of ad hoc perturbation
schemes for the worker characteristics
at one time snapshot we work we were
able to develop an algorithm to protect
the home locations of workers I won't go
into the details as algorithms they're
not that interesting you can look in the
paper but essentially so were able to
infuse differential privacy into into
some part of their half their product
and this actually they actually liked it
a lot in fact even the disclosure to be
Birds really thought that they should
make a push and actually trying to get
differential privacy into all of their
all of their products I'll talk about
the adobe bridge a little more later and
so so for the last few months have been
working again with the same group trying
to take the entire data set in try to
release it since litigator that the
satisfied differential privacy for the
entire date and not just for a portion
of it okay so that sort of the context
so in inside of the last few months I I
just sort of found a few challenges that
I wanted to point out I'm not going to
talk really about algorithm but truly is
challenges so why challenge that I
thought would be there that dent appear
was what is epsilon and the reason is is
surprisingly their policy to are there
mindset towards epsilon is sort of like
Cynthia's mindset let us do something
let us get something that is reasonable
utility and let us see what epsilon it
is which is which is reasonable right
and so so that's one question that I did
not need to feel but there are other
other interesting questions so for
instance what our neighboring data sets
so should de Madrid is a different
individual should they defend a business
should be referring both or some other
complicated notion of neighboring data
sets I'm going to talk about the lot
board in the second part of the talk ok
so that was there was one important
question that came up and we thought
about this a lot the second as Adam
pointed out there's both sparsity and
high-sensitivity especially when your
businesses suppose you are in Durham the
biggest employer is good medicine by far
half the population of Durham actually
stays there so it doesn't really make
sense to say I look at two data sets
that differ in the presence and absence
of medicine because you're basically not
going to hit anything right and it turns
out that this happens a lot of times
especially we want to compute the
average or median employment for
business or earnings of an individual
since your data is pious is always going
to be one individual in the block or one
business in an area that's going to be a
big outlier that you cannot ignore right
because they are the main thing in that
in that place ok next thing is certain
properties are actually publicly known
and it's not necessary to protect those
properties so for instance it turns out
the existence of a business and certain
of its properties like location industry
and ownership is a public or private
it's ok to know that there exists a
business of that type and then the fact
that its employment is not not equal to
0 it's ok to raise that so what that
means for instance is that certain
certain sort of combinations in a domain
because they're 0 not as sampling zeroes
would actually structural 0 so you
actually you can leverage that but then
there are many such rules and so if you
use all of those rules then
becomes sort of complicated to
understand to reason about what you're
protecting what you're not reading so
that's the this is just one example of
things that are publicly known and so
you have to be careful as to how you try
to encode these kinds of logical
statements all right and then then there
is this problem which is that I am
trying to help this team develop
differentially private algorithms but
there are many other teams in the census
who have data sets that are related to
this data set right and so for instance
the HD is talking about workplace and
work employer and employee demographics
but of course there are other senses
product that really is just population
statistics right and ideally you want
the statistics in in one organization to
be consistent to the statuses other
organization right but then you are
differentially private releases don't
compose well with not differentially
private releases even in terms of
privacy the in terms of privacy right so
if you have a non private release and
you have private release then you can
combine the two to infer more
information about individuals right so
just to give you a very very simple
example let's say I had a two
dimensional data set okay I had a two
dimensional data set and I wanted to
release the counts in each of the cells
very straightforward I can just use
Laplace mechanism and I'm done right I
get differential privacy with
sensitivity one now suppose I actually
have this but somebody else released the
exact row and column sums so I have one
row two column one column two right now
if in addition to this I have these
counts ETA 1 ETA 2 ETA 3 eater for right
I can get better estimators for all of
these all of these comes just because I
have four constraints that I can liken
you is to get for sort of unbiased
estimators for this for this cell and I
can drive down the variance of each of
these cons no it does in sense that the
the resulting epsilon
that you get is going to be different
yes it is for here so the so the
auxiliary information here is not about
an individual the auxiliary information
here actually correlates individuals a
big difference between epsilon 0 epsilon
delta differential prices are right if
we know that the whole thing hashes it
did a code or it has just to something
you can use this to break like crazy
that's on delta and yet that's 10 your
lower bound you guys go around run them
and get your releasing still holds yes
so the yeah so the information loss is
still getting free has fluorescence it's
still smart that's right but it's not
the same epsilon that he can effectively
you get a larger epsilon like a more
dramatic example of this as suppose you
know suppose you learn exactly the
differences in population between all 50
states right like I learned you know
Alabama minus California Alabama United
States okay no no let's do no let's do
50 then because it changes that the math
and yeah i can write down exactly what
is talking okay so so let's say i have a
bunch of counts mr. green a histogram
right so i have a histogram c 1 c 2 and
so on till ck okay and now i have
constraints of the form r1 is equal to
c1 plus c2 these are exact constraints
are two is equal to c2 plus c3 are 3 is
equal to c 3 plus c4 and so on RK minus
one equal to c k minus 1 plus c k right
so these are exact constraints
right and now if I if I release if I
release all of these cons were just
Laplace mechanism with sensitivity one
which makes sense now essentially what
they get it is now using these
constraints let's say let's take see one
I have one estimate c 1 tilde which
comes from the original replies
mechanism i have another constraint c 1
tilde to which is basically r 1 minus c
1 tilde right let the second estimator
it's an independent estimator of the
first one an unbiased i can get a third
estimator by using c2 c3 and then r1 and
r2 right i can basically telescopically
create into k minus 1 independent
estimators and now the variance that i
have on this on this st on this
estimator actually can be reduced by
averaging by a factor of K minus 1 so in
some sense I guess what's happening is
given your other constraints the sense
if the histogram doesn't have
sensitivity it was thank you exactly he
doesn't have sense already one anymore
here's computed from the data sets on a
neighboring instance exhilarate
information would also be different
exactly right and the questions all
right so yeah so that's one there are
other sort of legal things where you may
need certain codes marginal should be
exact and not based on sampling in other
looks so it's that and then there are
two problems that I've never heard of
before which are interesting one is
basically based on missing data so this
is a data integration system so it is
taking data from various different
sources and integrating it of course
there's got a missing data your
non-response due to miss the bad joints
and so on and what what almost all
statistical organizations do is they
take the data that is there and impute
values for the so the missing values in
your in your dataset yes I understood
the missing responses what was the other
one about Joyce um so so many cases you
don't have the correct keys to join
across data sets so for instance you may
not have a social security number or if
you have such educated number you can
have errors in the social security
number and so you have to do sort of
fuzzy joints and you do fuzzy joints
then you can actually have mistakes when
you do your you do a chance right and so
things that actually should our joint
would not not be there and so you're
sort of missing records in it right and
so the typical way to solve the problem
is through what is known as imputation
and so the there are many ways in which
you do it the standard technique is
called multiple imputation where you
build a model for any value or any
column in your data set and for any
missing value you use this model to
impute not one but many samples for that
for that value so you get not one but
sort of K data sets well the key data
sets all the values that are that are
actually present in the data the same
but the variables that does not present
their different draws from this random
distribution okay now this is a
pre-processing step if it was stable
then there's no problem you can just a
different the privacy but it's not right
i mean it's not going to depend only
this value it's going to depend on the
entire data set and also so you could
always think about this data set of 10
different data sets think of each of
these as real data points and sort of
say oh i have 10 data sets and i just
want to apportion epsilon but that seems
sort of wasteful right because really if
the data is actually there it's going to
be the same across all the things and
the things that are differing only sort
of random draws from some distribution
so there should be definitely be a
better way to do this okay so this is an
important problem I think and this is
almost every sort of social scientist or
registration as I've talked to they have
this happening in their data sets and so
if you want to help them we need to
understand and solve this problem we'll
try to make this private the point is
they're doing this imputation in order
to be able to carry out some other
processes like joints and they don't
know no 99 Giants to actually build
sadistically models on top of that to do
regression for instance or to do
so so if you have missing data there are
there are sort of two ways of handling
missing data one is you can just ignore
the rose that I of the missing data but
that's really wasteful and also it
induces a bias in that in the in the in
the fall and the subsequent statistical
analysis the 30 second the second way is
to ignore those rows Andrey wait the
remaining rows signaled rows that are
missing data entry with the rose that
actually have all the data the third
wave actually impute values for that
missing data now the imputation
technique is nice because especially the
multiple imputation technique is nice
because what it does is since you get
multiple data sets it actually not only
gives you possible values for that
missing value it also gives you an
estimate of the error that you have
introduced by making these imputations
and so so it's a nice Theory by don don
rubin from the 80s it basically says
that all need to do is if your
statistician is only analysis in each of
these and there are some nice formula is
that you can use to identify what is the
error that is that your sampling what is
the error that is their duty imputation
and so it's it's very well studied
theory and so they use it use it a lot
in their in their profits okay and then
this problem here is you more
interesting which is sometimes you may
have just errors in the data that you
used so for instance you may have gotten
data from some from some state database
and they made a mistake and they may be
dropped details about an entire county
or they reported old old readings for a
county and then retro actively they come
back and say oh I made a mistake in this
in this previous data can you go and fix
it I already used up your privacy
project to do something at this point of
time and you want to go back and fix
that thing and now the question is what
what does privacy mean in this in this
retroactive fixing fixing book it's not
it's not directly right so these are
some of the interesting challenges that
i found when when working with the the
sensor i thought that you guys might be
interested in hearing what the earth
looks like I already know out of time so
favorites okay so I'll try to quickly
goers soft my recent word that the tries
to solve this high sensitivity problem
and also tries to solve this thing and
basically it stems from my medicine the
recent word plants out of customizing
privacy protection to two applications
and it's all stems from this sort of
result that that has been seen over and
over again which is basically that it's
not possible to guarantee any utility in
addition to privacy without making
assumptions about the batter knowledge
this advice are available to an
adversary or sort of the data generating
distribution from which the the data is
drawn and in some sense even
differential tries he actually makes
assumptions about what the attacker
attacker really knows and you can't
really avoid making assumptions we need
when you define piracy and so there's
been sort of a bunch of work on making
these how do you make assumptions and
come up with sort of alternate models
for privacy I'm going to describe one of
these very quickly but essentially the
idea is that you want to specify clearly
what is being kept secret who your
adversaries are and how your information
disclosure is bounded okay and the next
few slides some of you might have seen
already but essentially the idea is that
you want to define so you can define
what your secrets are it turns of which
pairs of statements you want to hide
from the adversity right so for instance
you may have a stick figure to the farm
individuals records in the database and
pattern vigilance cancer versus
individual record is not in the database
and you want to you want to address it
not to be able to distinguish between
those two right and you can you can talk
about adversary's also in terms of what
kind of priors they they have and are
not going to go into details here all
I'm going to say is that differential
privacy is just an instantiation of such
a framework where basically your
adversary spire is any distribution that
makes the records independent and that
sort of this kind of an attack comes in
because here your records are no longer
independent okay let me sort of skip
through this quickly but essentially
what so when I talk to the census folks
about so
the sum of these things the thing that
they really liked that they really liked
was this part about specifying sensitive
information that actually helps you
identify sort of principal ways of
computing the neighboring databases so
let me let me spend a little more time
on that okay so i call it Blowfish
because it's another name for puffer
fish but essentially so i'm going to
talk about this so there are two things
that we do here we call a policy as a
combination of a specification of
sensitive information and a
specification of certain publicly known
constraints about the data that may
potentially correlate tuples like things
like this that may be known a priori
about the data set okay so let's look at
the specification of sensitive
information right so stricken a
sensitive information is basically a set
of pairs of such mutually exclusive
secrets that you don't want your
adversary to distinguish between so
under so if you look at the
indistinguishability notion of
differential privacy it basically
corresponds to all pairs of the form SI
x and SI y that for all x and y in the
domain of Ares IX is basically the
property that the record i takes the
value X in the domain okay and basically
don't want for any power of x and y you
don't want an adversary to distinguish
between the two of them right but in
reality you don't need you may not need
such kinds of protection you may you may
you may be okay with just having a
subset of these pairs being protective
so for instance you can you can consider
something like this where your partition
if you do domain p 1 2pm and now you
don't want an adversary to distinguish
any pair x and y that come within from
each of these partitions but it's
located disclose whether x and y are
different partitions so an example is if
you want to if you want to say it's okay
to disclose the existence of business
then you don't have any pair of the form
the employment of the business is 0 and
employment is your prisoner is greater
than 0 but all your pairs are with your
employment is within x and y where x and
y are actually positive numbers okay or
if you don't want to do okay to disclose
your healthy or not you don't have a
secret pair it says you're healthy us is
not something that is not healthy right
or you can have something like
distance-based sensitive information
where basically you say
there's some distance metric and you
only care about pairs X and Y that are
close according to that distance metric
so in your census block kiss you don't
want two distinct you want two distinct
not attack could not distinguish within
any close by pairs of blocks but it's
okay to distinguish between far away
blocks so to generalize this really you
can think about a graph G where we set
of values the individuals record can
take your domain and E is basically the
set of all pairs that you don't want to
address city to distinguish between
right and now in this graph the
intuition basically is that if x and y
are distance D apart on this graph then
in something the adversary should not be
able to distinguish them at the at the
level of e to the epsilon times D so for
every pair of neighboring values it's e
to the epsilon but greater it's it's it
scales are you to the D Tiger see you
can also have constraints I'm going to
sort of skip that and so basically your
neighboring tables now can be clearly
defined in terms of basically this graph
here and certain set of constraints that
you have and you can actually come up
with basically a formal definition of
what neighboring databases it's all
based on these two specifications okay
so let's see good just to consider a
very simple example suppose you can talk
about a line graph in terms of your
sensitive information because basically
you're 11 too much random and your
domain X 1 to X D and then you can say
that I should not be able to distinguish
it in any pair of consecutive buckets
but it's okay to distinguish between
things that are far away and they will
be protected with an e to the d epsilon
ability is a distance in the graph right
and it turns out that and so you can
just define different the privacy just
in terms of the neighbors here I turns
out that having this kind of flexibility
allows you to get get over certain
problems that we had in terms of high
sensitivity but also I think and there
is a conductor that we have is that you
can basically have error bound at a sort
of independent of the domain size but
dependent only on the complexity of this
sensitive graph well in samsung
differential privacy is a complete graph
which basically has a domain size
exercise X complete graph
is fairly dense but that is your things
like a line graph has very sparse and so
you can actually do things that are much
much better right so let's say a couple
of examples 1 is the employment of a
business if you have really high
business you can actually define an
interesting policy and this is actually
a policy that the census guys we sort of
like then this something that they think
about it is HP advice you should not be
retail and individuals earning or are a
business employment within a
multiplicative range of C ok it's
reasonable policy right answer it's a
simple algorithm which is really adding
nice to the log of this but it gives you
a multiplicative error of utmost c
square over epsilon it's fairly
straightforward right here and so your
error is not in terms of the entire
domain size but just the multiplicative
thing that is specified in your in your
policy and it turns out there's sort of
a general and I think I'm running over
or it's okay I turns out there's
actually a general methodology for
answering queries as well so if you have
for instance a workload of linear quiz
right and now you cannot you given up
your workload in your query in your
sensitivity of that workload under the
normal definition differential privacy
is basically the norm of the maximum
know of any of your columns right if you
are doing epsilon differential privacy
you just the the sum of all of these
columns the maximum of this and that
gives you a sensitivity so this is
basically your perfect some work load
right and there exists a very nice piece
of work called the matrix mechanism that
basically tells you how to optimally
answer these workloads you using a
different strategy matrix a so that you
can actually minimize the amount of
error that you introduced and basically
the idea is that you compute a different
work to retrieve workload that is a
smaller sensitivity but also has a can
reconstruct your W with a small number
of ways where your errors don't do not
add up an example of of this matrix
mechanism was the the binary tree
solution for the prefix sums that that
will be seen a couple of times already
right and the error can be sort of very
nicely captured in terms of the
arms of of the reconstruction as well as
the sensitivity of your strategy matrix
now it turns out you can actually
compute the bestest linear estimate
unbiased estimator of this workload and
there exists a lower bound on how much
the error of that of that estimator is
in terms of the SVD of this or the
singular values of that of that of that
workload I turns out under Blowfish you
can actually do something very similar
so so given any workload its sensitivity
basically can be computed as a product
of that as at the maximum norm of a
different matrix which is a product of
the original workload and another
another matrix that comes from your
graph and basically if you have a line
graph for instance then your sensitivity
is basically the maximum norm of
difference of those columns right and so
I just a product of this and another
matrix are just different on your graph
right now it turns out at least when the
ground these graphs are trees so except
with a line line graph if the if you
have an optimal strategy AG in forth for
a matrix WG which is the product of your
original workload and this and this
graph then the optimal strategies
lording over clear w is just AG times i
G inverse so in fact you can actually go
for a loon workload and then convert or
different metrics and just do the matrix
values for normal differential privacy
and then get back the optimal strategy
and this or a straight forward to see
that under the line graph the
sensitivity of this workload is one so
you can also answer it directly rather
than doing anything more fancy and so
essentially it seems like looking at
these sort of different notions of
differential privacy or neighboring
databases it's sort of similar to taking
your original domain transform working
in transforming it in some way and then
just doing differential privacy analysis
on top of that and and that
transformation basically depends on the
properties of this of this graph that
you have and of course you can always
get you can all eat since it's so
straight forward you can actually get a
similar SVD type bound even for when you
have these funny of this graph and you
can actually get much better utilities
in terms of
in terms of these bounds and also in
terms of the actual a business and so I
think this is a I mean initially I
didn't really think there was sort of
promise in trying to just look at these
differing neighboring databases but
there seems to be something interesting
going on here in terms of the kinds of
utility you can get and it may just be
in terms of the the X term of the log X
term that comes in these bounds but of
course all constants matter actually
doing something important right and the
census let's eat a large also because
you can use these policies to actually
make logical statements and understand
what pairs you are protecting and what
facts you're not and to what extent and
so the sum from some brief description
brief meetings with the discretionary
board I think they like it because they
sort of give get to get more control on
what they are actually trying to protect
or they're not and the current state of
the added for the diff Larry Bird's or
that they basically get the algorithm
that is being used and they're too poor
or the algorithm and see whether it is
good or bad and this seemed a much
better much better for them and that's
it so that I leave you for questions yes
generalized version of that sort out my
name is amiss nice job to move among all
experimental okay and also the power
bound raised below but if you show you
what the involve factors oh that's rule
over about 40 x 35 stratagems sounds
good and it's also maybe Justin you've
like some simple working that it
resulting applied any increase this
bloke you're saying so yeah I look at
that that's really promising them that's
good right thank you
you